yeah welcome to this video a 15 minute
game this time and I'm playing luckier
against 1.e4 what kind of opening let's
play something else don't think I ever
played the other kind you know I often
defense or something like this and on
video maybe once or twice okay but we
transpose Dow into a Vienna and now into
four nights so this is more like what I
know
yeah Bishop c4 yeah a Knight takes e4
it's a good answer not the only one but
supposed to be the the best
yeah Bishop takes f7 it's a mistake
really it's now black gets a big center
and the two bishops the King position is
not a big deal I can easily go to g8 and
play something like h6 kh7 later I lose
some time because of this King issue but
the center and the bishop a small pond
also instead of what I just mentioned
this h6 some thing this is weird
hmm okay I need to think about this now
as um it looks like um white is
sacrificing material here if I move the
King and this is not only for his attack
then g5 is hanging so let's say I would
play King to g8 for example then the
only way for him to to justify this is
to play something like winner three
threatening mate and need to be cautious
here this is certainly not working but
in order to refute it I must be a must
be precise I would say one one point
could also be what if I play a king 2-1
to g6 even Queen f3 and Kappa take it
for Queen f7 King g5 and then a move of
the D pawn I'm probably probably lost
after this
so maybe King g6 is a bit too much but I
can I can invest a bit of time I mean
I'm I just need to to play correctly and
win this is this I'm pretty certain of
yeah probably just kingi idiom kingi
edges are normal Queen f3 and what then
on f7 there is a maid threat and if I
would cover or if I were if I covered
with the Queen each 7 then he probably
has some tactical moves maybe even maybe
even Knight c3 as Queen g5 s Queen takes
d5 leading to checkmate
so King g8 Queen f3
how do I do I have some some good way to
cover up 7 without compromising anything
I also have 94 at some point need to
take this into account so let's say King
g8 Queen f3 Queen e7 93 94 and so 25
here
so 25 okay then Queen d7
kingi a tweener 327 93 94 threatens on
c2 but a g5 is not hanging anymore okay
whatever whatever whatever I went to g8
just for argument's sake he could play
on Queen h5 also g6 Queen f3 which would
weaken a bit that f6 square okay I need
to move at some point so Queen f3 27 was
my idea Knight c3 Knight 2 1 to deform
it doesn't seem to win outright but it
looks it looks good I mean I hope I hope
I hope this is at least one way to get
some advantage you know this King g6 was
was really really a bit too much where
we saw this
Qing Yi seven looks completely
completely bonkers and King head
yeah maybe King e8 this was maybe an
alternative ok this was clear now he's
threatening on on f7 27,000 Knights III
but I'm not 93 I can play he falls all
right
I cannot take g5 because of Queen defy
him the funny funny chick made but if oh
of course I could go in for him okay
what if if he goes to some other square
can go to g3 but still if for okay so
Queenie 793 if for Queen somewhere there
somewhere where also protects g5 so to
g3m he needs to go to g3 and then g5 is
is hanging yeah it's it should be it
should be fine for black with more than
one move even aged six is good I'm not
sure what's better Queen d7 or Queen e7
well if something looks somehow shaky
like a queen takes d5 if white at some
point comes to d5 it's it's really a
maid but I don't see how how he should
should know about this okay I may be on
Queenie 70 can play 96 this looks like a
weird move
but 96 I can play you for probably Queen
f7 looks totally totally ridiculous and
Queenie some okay let's go Queen d7 I'm
not sure
so 1964 Queen f7 check Queen takes
Knight X we have a situation where I can
probably play h6
and his Knight a some is some it's not
them getting out 96 is a really cool
move okay I could take but the porn
queen d5 Bishop d6
it's not it's not necessarily bad but I
suspect you will play Knight c3 anyway I
move like night c5 I mean I could so I
could play your form just the same as
all night 93 okay this I didn't consider
at all okay yeah well do you find the
same so the natural move would be a
Bishop to e6 M there should be six Queen
b7 lon is there some way to protect this
it should be six yeah I can just take p7
and I don't see a move okay
not the move you you like to play but
how exactly does he continue yeah now
I've got 94 right what are you doing now
I'm threatening on c2 at the end let me
add this thread anyway I thought I think
I really was fine it wasn't a problem
but just looking weird but what having
this threads wouldn't be three bedtime I
mean I've got the center and those
Knights don't have any squares really
and they don't have any any strong
points that they can use right now I'm I
really don't see what weiter
should should go play now I mean I'm
just playing quit taking on C to twenty
five twenty five ninety five ninety two
and takes on a1 this is just the rook
maybe can ya probably can trap the the
night in the corner so that it would
would be an exchange at the end
yeah okay not you know no choice and now
let's grab this and the question is can
you really trap this piece all right
should I play Bishop g4 check and
whoopsie AIDS gaining a tempo and
controlling c2 in the process probably
and this is a good idea
Bishop g4 up c ed and alright don't see
a drawback now attacking the c7 night
and if it returns to or goes to
something like b5 or d5 I'll just play a
Bishop f5 and then I have 92 - to make
it an extra rook and not an extra
exchange with just a big difference of
course now I really don't see a move I'm
thinking needs to to move the knight now
I could take g4 let's say let's let's
look at this quickly text before I take
c7 and then I play Knight c2 next move
okay if he it takes my rook with 96 I
need to move the rook for us but he
cannot really am I think prevent night
c2 to d4 back or c2 to be form
ya know it's investing time or the rook
down it's a bit late okay so just to f5
I guess yeah
I need to go here so that I have to see
two square available in case he plays
Knight c3 to UM block the rooks
influence on c2 so okay so um 96 okay so
probably let's just let's just grab this
and play I'm not see to keep it simple
if you place night a seven capturing I
can go to a eight and detect this this
night so that both both nights are hain
and on any neutral move up a night
before our D form
came so that's not not much of a
difference where I where I go yeah maybe
maybe exchange more the night is of
course stronger than the bishop but
exchanging some pieces with an extra
rook is usually good I need to get this
h8 rook into play though otherwise extra
Brooke doesn't mean much effort in the
cone all the time yeah what if I capture
now then I activate this root camp I buy
a lot um maybe just just cover this and
you cannot develop his Bishop which is a
good thing so yeah maybe just Bishop to
Bishop here he plays 95 I have an idea
for check simplifying further you know
Knight f4 Chucky what he needs to drop
back then king d3 kinking f3 would we
have of with rope d3 check
yeah basically everything wins yeah well
okay yeah
what is this down it's really a big
material advantage rook and rook and an
exchange or something like this how to
count even okay so let's keep it simple
and just get get t5 getting rid of
nights that's often a good idea and in
blitz games so that you don't get into
some crazy fork and this is really easy
now push up T for getting the bishop to
a dominating position so that he almost
needs to exchange it
kh5 G form
utilizing the sixth report on the
kingside yeah Matt's activate the rook
he probably will play to mate I mean if
you don't resign up to now you doesn't
make them make sense to look for
continuation that making resign you
probably won't anyway okay so the f-bomb
just promotes now let's check quickly
the first moves I like to know how to
refute this properly
yeah no surprise that the computer gives
me plus three here it wants to play king
e8 King Aid and Queen f3 was was the
thing that slightly worried me but this
is really easy right this is easy
Night Moves I can just grab it on g5 so
I was I was also slightly worried about
this but now I have this move yam and
this this is really really easy
what doesn't even have a meaningful
check here okay so King yet is probably
easier but I hope King g8 wins as well
yeah it does
according to computer Queen f3 and now
Queen d7
yeah and it's it's winning at least I
found one winning continuation and now
the computer wants it with 93 still
giving me a winning advantage but the
problem is simply that white doesn't
have any squares for his pieces
so we'll just for example age six night
back end oops you form and this is
really terrible this is not on because
of Queenie six winning a piece and now
the night here has no square really
needs to drop back and then I've got
even this here yeah it leads to central
dominance because why dumb with this
this open you you simply ignore the
center black gets a big center and
return for just a couple of King moves
and two bishops which of the long run is
really really really bad the relatively
best move of things probably not g3 but
it's it's it's rather it's rather
terrible yeah thanks for watching